Hey  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  three-point basket  [Applause]  that was riskier animation  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  buh-bye how long so  [Applause]  jaelyn luck you  [Applause]  [Applause]  and in gym by Jaylon  [Applause]  that was  three-point basket  [Applause]  ten three-pointer by Terrence Clark will  count  [Applause]  that was five  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  three-point Peskin my car  god  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  des Moines for Terrance pork  and then  [Applause]  three point  turn around  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  do white  once again that blood sky Jones and  they're reversed look  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  hi